wenn du eine kartoffel wär's dann wärst
du eine süßkartoffel andere kartoffeln
gibt noch speisekartoffeln die kann man
speisen herzlich willkommen die heute zu
einer weiteren folge da kann man auch
mal klatschen reger heutige folge oracle
habe ich mir den kommentar von dem
lieben user namens praxen zu herzen
genommen und zwar schreibt er ich soll
schlechte anmachsprüche bringen das
heisst losgehen
da haben wir uns nicht schon in der
letzten folge gesehen
wir haben uns noch nie gesehen habe ich
euch verwechseln gutmann empfehlung für
das heutige oracle video habe ich mir
immer wieder ein thema überlegt und zwar
habe ich anmachsprüche vorbereitet ist
dein vater ein dieb denn er hat die
sterne vom himmel gestohlen und in deine
augen gesehen
ich werde mich nicht ich habe noch einen
zweiten für euch hast du mal kleingeld
ich habe meiner mutter versprochen sie
anzurufen wenn ich meine traumfrau
gefunden habe ich gut
hey hey ich glaub du bis schalke fan
oder auch bayern habe ich nicht erkannt
da stimmt ich habe anmachsprüche
vorbereitet und ich würde ja deine
meinung hören wenn ich in den club gehe
und mädchen treffen ob ich diesen spruch
bringen sollte ich gehen in eine bar und
ein mädel und ich sag dann einfach zu
ihr ich habe so einen trockenen mund du
hast nicht vielleicht eine nasse zum für
mich mich nicht bringt hey hey hey wie
gehts ist gerade nacht bei die oder
warum ist das so schwarz aber du ich
habe für die heutige folge auch wenn
deine kamera gerade schrott ist habe ich
[Musik]
alles gut ich habe zeit ich nehme kein
video auf 2000 jahre später
ich habe für die heutige folge habe ich
anmachsprüche vorbereitet kann ich heute
nacht bei dir schlafen mein bett ist
kaputt ja das
[Musik]
ich habe auch jetzt warte ich hab doch
die hängen an der wand erstmal schön
dich zu treffen
ich habe mir für die heutige oracle
folge überlegt dass ich anmachsprüche
habe ich mir ausgedacht und habe mir
gedacht ich trage die meinen zuschauern
hier mal vor und schauen mal was sie
davon halten
glaubst du an liebe auf den ersten blick
oder soll ich noch mal reinkommen
was kannst du eigentlich hey du kommst
mir so bekannt vor du siehst aus wie
meine nächste freude war ja okay da ist
müsste das ist das erste mal dass jemand
einen von mir vorbereiteten anmachspruch
gut finde sehr sehr lieb von bier kennst
du noch ein guten anmachspruch ich habe
nicht mehr so viel hast du eine ziel
will ich die ganze nacht
okay dass ich gleich jetzt nächste
arbeitest du bei der nasa zu lustig also
ich habe gerade mit einem mädel hier
gesprochen und sie hat mir einen mega
mega guten anmachspruch gesagt wo sie
meinen dass sie den richtig gut findet
deswegen würde ich den jetzt einfach mal
dir vorlesen und ihr sagen und du musst
mir deine meinung dazu sagen okay wenn
du eine tür wärst würde ich dich die
ganze nacht knallen
ich habe aber noch ein zweiter für dich
kannst du mir deine telefonnummer geben
ich habe meine vergessen idee falsch
verloren hat ich habe noch einen dritten
ist es hier wirklich so heiß oder liegt
es an dir du bist so heiß dass ich sogar
verbrannt an deiner hand aus kittels
[Musik]
kindles
cages menschlich sind ziemlich abstoßend
das geld ja du ich hab das heutige video
habe ich mir immer wieder ein thema
überlegt und zwar habe ich anmachsprüche
vorbereitet und möchte gern mal deine
meinung dazu hören
und welcher wolke bist du denn gefallen
mein engel verdammte scheiße ich habe
aber noch einen zweiten hast du mal
einen stift für mich damit ich mir deine
nummer aufschreiben kann
verdammte scheiße halte ich toll finde
ich nicht gut darin
hallo ich heiße luca aber gottes auch
okay du bist gerade live auf
installieren
ach du bist auf instagram gerade live
nebenbei ja so das ist eine insel saite
kleiner lucent gerade live wie ich dir
fällt da bin aktiver derzeit sogar ein
handy in stegen zukunft die nasa
mitarbeiterin einer freundin geht's dann
richtig scheiße trennt sie jetzt
wahrscheinlich schon im freund im ernst
wenn sie anmachsprüche braucht für neuen
typen alles gute ich übernehmen dass ich
kann dir noch einen sagen wenn du willst
den kanzler dann an sie weiterleiten
hallo ich bin der möbelpacker kann ich
dir beim ausziehen helfen macht das auch
wenn sie sich trend gar kein problem hat
sie direkt neuen freundin doch hier bin
ich warte doch ist das moment ist das
ein ticket pudel entenjagd kenne ich gar
nicht aber er ist trotzdem sauer süß
alter cookie ja aber ich mache das
heutige video eigentlich nicht wegen
hundetag sondern er ich hab mir mal
wieder ein thema überlegt für orgel und
zwar werde ich habe einige
ich habe anmachsprüche rausgesucht tun
dir die beine nicht weh du gehst mir
schon den ganzen abend durch den kopf
nicht so aber okay ich habe noch einen
zweiten für dich willst du die mutter
meiner kinder werden
naja ok warte ich habe aber noch einen
glaubst du an liebe auf den ersten blick
oder muss ich noch mal reinkommen
ehrlich ja ok hab ich zumindest eine
sache hier hinbekommen juli möchte noch
mal ganz kurz deinen hund sehen daher
kann ich jude mal ganz kurz eben holen
ja also publikum richtig verwertet kommt
aus dem norden da kommst du hässlich
heften nach oben geht es über das
massaker also du wirst auch wir
wahrscheinlich nicht gerade
ich habe für die heutige folge oracle
habe ich anmachsprüche vorbereitet und
würde gerne deine meinung zu diesem
spruch hören wenn du eine kartoffel wärs
dann wärst du eine süßkartoffel andere
kartoffeln
naja es gibt noch speisekartoffeln die
kann man speisen
begrüßen deine stadt ja wie heißt deine
stadt schreibt mal rein
heppenheim schöne grüße an ganz
heppenheim
er stellt ihr euch das heutige
winterzeit ist auch beenden meine lieben
freunde der letzte anmachspruch jetzt
gerade kam nicht so gut an
andere gucken wenn der regel mit luca
gefallen hat würde ich mich sehr sehr
sehr sehr toll aber einen daumen hoch
von euch hier unter dem video freuen
schaffen wir 50.000 daumen hoch das wäre
mégane ist und das wird mir zeigen hey
ihr habt bock auf diese serie und ich
soll nächste woche einen erneuten part
hochladen schreiten auf jeden fall jetzt
schon in die kommentare was das thema
der nächsten regel folge sein soll also
werten letzte woche witze heute hatten
wir anmachsprüche und das nächste woche
kommen soll dürft ihr entscheidende
unten in den kommentaren abonniert main
kanal falls sie noch kein teil der
luxury seit und jetzt kommt das auto
[Musik]